мій данте на 200 мільйонів людей у ​​свиті
інфе купався коронавірусом втомлюємося годиною
кільки заражені але зростає через
дельта варіант в 1 годину менше людей
хоче вакцину wat is a job тікають від
ціни на ефективний проти його варіант
1 клич правда c ще перевіряється твердиня
ми згорнулася пекла університетської
клініки бонна з 1 знає великих лікарі не
машини ми поговоримо з праведними ми дико
ми обидва тут уват і я окремо варіант
спливаючи на зараження
liqueur єнс кристіан шеф просив і
переконав і не інтенсивної терапії теж
проти кого ушп італію this дельта
варіантом вже мало хто повністю вакцина
ванною
кран клеї я все тремтять і на рахунок 99
адже сотки у пацієнтів за ваш комп'ютер риб
в мені як ми тріумфував і в лазні або ви
ще плані щось невідомо можна зробити
виставок ще вакцинація ясна забороняє
при нас не вигляд вашого кого перебігу хвороба
з нами фриз
out так смішно
я захищаю вакцинації дельта
варіанті вісь відчувають люди усопп
ша консул familia
можна сексу в такому сдм трюму слів і
давок з вакцина набрати або
тих тільки що вакцини вигляд
коронавірусу узо галини проти правда
ніхто не частоти стику свічка 97 особа
таких заражений коронавірусом у не меч і
не нині пропадаючи на дельта варіант
in these спеціалізації з тим варіантом
вище-нижче з початку
вакцини гілку рано вірусу дають варто
сотку вайза host with дельта варіанті ми
правда, а корінь з'їдено чутно в кому
експертів та наука вам їду газом та вітри
основні причини чому деки повністю
акційного не людом з ще раз uid
серйозно заходить і обидва пум rt вигляд дельта
варіанти
або що у брата довго ефективність
вакцин кращого і все ж однозначно так
е стоїть сотню вова закон ставить ковен 19
до щура мені з вами натан учена команда
на пазурі в середню організацію охорони
здоров'я ви на котячі всі вакцини до
допомагають за 6 тис або дельти та
альду кузей вакцини адже захищаєте
зараження різьбленого світу та закладено вигляд
вакцини all ще діяв і його ч всього
на захищають вид у школу перебігу хвороби
тут
він нас причинність до ефективності
вакцин з лобка йому на вигляд по до
цих людей та
мемберс йому навік по ж у різьблених людей
брудно і на не спливаючи нас кофакторів
так вик про dance таких факторів аджі йому
на вигляд по зовсім маленьких дітей і
людей мужиків та лаву вику зазвучати
локшина нижчу здорових дорослих
граничних в робота iншi фактор поверх
може спливати на імунну він
він подумки подруга прощавай на на
ефективність вакцини можете спливати
великої ще їхня пряма люди знаходиться
фігура люди які зловлять так дзвони йому на
супресори обама та трансплантологи
органи не душа добра буде на вакцини
[музика]
високу ефективність дозволених вакцин
експерт поважаєте ще й зараз він їх не
вони також змінюються третя причина
застиг є вакцини зараз він знижується
і деки люди за нещасливих обставимо все
а може серйозно захопить
ви знання вакцина гілку через не за б
поспішати дістань його за хасту про те
дельта варіанту неправда
я найкраща врятуй він і батога вже живив і
не оновить смерті вендель то варіантом
повністю намагайся ревінь ефективності
вакцин бізнес у клініч знайду зниження
то при практичному застосуванні у різьблених
краях до неї ще допущених з
препаратів свічка tes і вакцини на дають
душа високий ступінь за хасту
акорд заданим їжу слідування з канади
ефективність препарату баян так фейзер
про ти зараження дельта варіантом
встановіть 56 адже сотки якщо більшу
дозу чапліні та 87 900 км якщо повні
вакцинації
а якщо за дев'янистим до відомостей
модерну треба їй 7 10 2 вид стільниковий
адже захист зараження коронавірусом вже
після першої дози може бути повноцінне
даних сюди за хосту після двох доз
німа
дослідження у британії здалося
чаплині препаратом astrazeneca треба ї за
хвіст у сімдесят один вид соток якщо
великі дози та 92 листи інший
джон сина японія johnson & johnson
stranger ще й і вакцина гінер у я під
потрібну йому ну вигляд купити праску конкретних
цифр якани закладених даних диво
препарату на
маусі про ітан давай експерти procon вони
ще вакцини ефективно захищають
дельта варіантом
вакцинація ефективний інструмент align
їжі ще контролювати цю інфекцію в
arduino дали що мелений заходь у
індивідуальної захисту години та години
навесні фарш та результату до сліди
засвічує рахунок дельта варіанти та бірж
раз стенд на льоду вакцин проте пам'ятаю
сильно вакцинація зараз забезпечуючи під
вушні захльостує види del teide союзу
зустрічав нові дезінформацію ще до
коронавірус в обидва вакцин яку нам у роті
було б перевірити і за видами ти нам у
коментарях обидва напасти на куприка не
біда банком
[музика]